uh
had everything stolen from me again last
night
just everything
stuff that wasn't mine
um
i was just chasing somebody down the
road and i'm like there's a third one
this week
seriously third one
i'm just like i i should learn my lesson
right now you know
okay i knew better
and i still i was sleeping
and i knew better
if this happens on a daily basis to
people
let's get wrong every day
like if you're not on your toes
if you if you you don't have somebody
watching your back you can't go to sleep
yeah people sleep and lose everything
i knew better man i knew better
just trying to get comfortable it's no
comfortability
how long you've been down here that's
good
really now
coming around for a good
good year now i was from kensington
yeah kensington
from the east coast yeah
how has now you've been here a year
how's skid row compared to kensington
it's
it's it's the closest thing you can get
you can
i'd say
the closest
they're pretty similar yeah it's a
little bit cleaner
cleaner here i think
so yeah you still got your girl
no
what happened though it was split
slipping someone
it's got to get you down
sorry about that
yeah it's one of the tougher things i've
had to deal with
moon's still fresh
it's been a while and
it's it's it's crazy because even in
skid row it's like
it's like a little high school everybody
like
knows each other
you know so like everybody sees her
and like it's every time they see me
they're like oh what's up with her like
oh like this and that and it's like a
little
like they're like it's like a little
drama skit you know
it's just um
it's everything everything
people do out here
they try to like bring you down so that
they can be up because
everybody is trying to get ahead on
somebody so they can
so they can continue their high
or they can
look better than than you or something
along those lines
everybody's trying to trying to get one
over on some money
i'm just not trying to be that person
and it's because
and there's a lot of other people that
are like that out here that are trying
to do the right thing but they
they all get [ __ ] over
yeah there are some good people down
here yeah honest good people
absolutely but for every one of those
there's 50 hustlers mm-hmm
you got you got to be hustle and you got
you got to be a hustler or be hustled
that's it
it's hard to put your guard down
and just relax
be yourself if you're a honest good
person because
there's a hustle coming down the street
every minute
yeah
it's literally like
i knew better
and i knew better and so i'm saying that
not just last night
i knew but i knew i was going to be here
i knew that this was going to be where i
was at if i didn't stop [ __ ] up
how's the drug use
changed
same it's getting worse
i'm shooting up like
not caring
you're using fentanyl right
which is pretty much the most hardcore
of the hardcores
put on crack
with a drag man
just turn it against all your friends
people look at you different
do you feel like you have friends down
here real friends
are these just
street associates
i have some
people that have my back they're not my
friends so
i have some
it's people that want to see me do
better
i'm considered as friends
but i don't trust them it's just kind of
like
you know how is that like really
different i understand you can't judge
nobody man yeah a person's nature's
changes when they start doing some of
these drugs
i mean the the
scandalous behavior of a drug addict is
it never ceases to amaze
the me will do the most
unbelievable things
and i can't say that i'm not i'm not a
saint and any respect
um i've been a scandal you know what i
mean
i'm a graffiti artist i do i've been
doing illegal things my entire life
you know
but that's why i say i knew better i
knew i was gonna end up in this
situation
i knew it
and everybody told me it's like even me
i've like
tried to warn other people like hey look
like this is you know who am i to give
advice to anyone
because like and that's how everybody
down here they always giving advice to
other people
like somebody told me the other day like
i'm done taking advice from homeless
people
you know
because like
who are you to give advice to me
but we've all had experiences and we've
all actually like experienced like we
all
have done the wrong thing and ended up
with the wrong outcome
to tell somebody else how to do it
but we're not taking our advice half the
time
that's where i [ __ ] up
how old do you know
i'm 26 26 still very young
do you think you're self-destructive
absolutely
since
since me my my fiance's my ex-fiance
split up
i've kind of like been down this road
where
at first i was like i'm gonna try to um
you know build myself back up and like
try to you know do better and like
like outwin her
but then that wasn't it i'm just right
now i'm kind of just like not giving a
[ __ ] and
where i ended up sleeping under bridges
and like
like really sticking a needle back in my
arm after not doing it for so long
that's what did it and i know now i'm
just doing it because i don't care about
my life
it was getting clean
one of the things you were thinking
about maybe doing just to kind of better
yourself and
yeah i even got on this boxing script
and uh you tried doing that but that's
not getting clean but it was one step in
the right direction
trying to get off
a phenom
trying to get all the signals yeah but
if you get depressed get
self-destructive then
it's hard to stay on any positive track
mix it with coming off a crack
the depression
and and then no
then
not feeling any pleasure
not having fun on not feeling any
pleasure from that
i oh my gosh
just the thoughts i was having walking
down this road just now
yeah what are you thinking
so
so heartbreaking to see so many people
like yourself who have so much potential
you can do great things with your life
and you're just stuck
it's like you're in quicksand and you
just can't get out
i know that i'm blessed beyond
proportion
but sometimes
i don't see those things it gets clouded
yeah
it gets clouded from drugs in
all the [ __ ]
after doing all these interviews i think
the thing i've learned is it's mental
illness at the core of all these
problems it's not the drug it's the
it's definitely not homelessness it's
definitely not the drug it's i think
it's mental illness
and that comes from who knows what
something
yeah it could be genetic could be
something you went through as a kid it
could be whatever
but that's that's the core problem
and the drugs are a nice escape from
whatever pain you're going through or
depression you're going through or
the anxiety or whatever
and to stop using the drug
doesn't fix the
the mental
issue that's underlying that
and then that becomes a problem and the
drugs come right back into your life
people don't realize that like
mental illness and drug addiction it
runs in your family you pass to your
kids
you know
not only that it's when they say it's a
family disease
it
affects your family so it's not just you
affected like you're affected
your family is affected from your
addiction too which therefore will
affect
their little family's lives and stuff
like that you know what i mean it
affects everybody it affects everybody
are your parents addicts or alcohol yeah
yeah
my whole family is it i can't i gotta
say anybody that's my entire family yeah
you know that's one form of addiction or
something mental just
something
you know it's a whole family disease
absolutely my mom and dad specifically i
guess it'd be worse
but
yeah i interviewed someone yesterday
who's in the same situation you're in
basically right now
but they were raised in a perfect family
but they were adopted
and he checked into what his uh
biological parents were all about and
they were both addicts
so
that seems to point a finger at
that it's some kind of inherited
behavior
not always but sometimes people don't
realize it it's passed down
it's passed down
and somewhere along the line you got to
cut it off
you know
you have to stop it
if i don't stop if i ever end up having
kids
i don't i don't know if i i'd want to
because i don't want a kid to go yeah
so with being down here on skid row
where you you're living on the street
you're losing your belongings on the
daily every time you fall asleep yeah
every time you fall asleep every time
you fall asleep you lose everything and
it's just such a horrible
starting point to try to straighten your
life out
because you get a baseball bat to the
knees every
every three days
yeah it's horrible down here
but i mean
it's
it's hope there's still
i think that there's still hope that's
why i didn't want to tell you that like
when my thoughts were going down here
because i don't wanna i don't wanna be
like i don't want to be
i wanted to think it in the truth you
know what i mean i just want there to be
hope
you know
i don't want that to be a reality i just
want to to remain
hopeful try to
because that's the only way that i'm
gonna i'm gonna come out of it as if
that's that's what i learned
in the past being sober and being like
being in recovery and and bringing
myself out of those those depressions
and bringing myself off the streets
and getting better
is that i changed that um
i changed the thought process from
negative positive and it's hard it's
like a practice thing that i've like
i've had to practice
but like i have to change from negative
to positive and and
from ungrateful to grateful
and just remain grateful and remind
myself in a blessed
i'm blessed for a lot of things
yeah i totally can see you i can totally
imagine you as a
upstanding member of society just doing
your thing figuring out what your career
is and just applying yourself without
these
without all the crap you're going
through now
you know the drug addiction is going to
stop you from whatever you want to do
but if you broke free of that and got
off the street and
somehow got your life straight i mean i
can see you
living a great life very easily
you have so many great qualities
thank you
i'm working on it
yeah you're just talking with your
family help at all
and they're going through the same kind
of crap
so when you talk to them you don't even
talk to them
so you're really on your own
kind of
[Music]
you know i was a
girl and that's gone but
i still believe in god
so
i'm not on my own completely
you can do it but
with your family history and
with your current situation just know
that it's going to be tough
i mean
it's been tough
and this i guess it's not
i've had all my shits done before
because it's not that bad it happens a
lot because i have it's not like i had a
lot less stuff stolen now yeah
you guys think it's not that bad
probably helps to talk about it all
right yeah it does
and being on the street you don't have
anybody to talk to right
not anybody no
you just can't trust anybody
for some people i think i'm like their
therapist and they just like they need
to come in here and talk and i'm like
across the street
i can only i can only take so much of
this a day yeah i was like oh my gosh
no i was looking for you so i'm glad you
came back
that's cool
now ever since your first talk with me i
i just thought you had so much potential
so smart so talented so
you've got all these great qualities
but you're here
and it's like
it's tragic
it's tragic and to break that cycle you
know your family's
history and all that it's going to take
a major
undertaking on your part
yeah
but people do it
there's still a ton of success stories
you know i've been i've been to plenty
of meetings and been to plenty of of uh
just like churches and
seen so many success stories and
witnessed them myself going through
rehab after rehab after rehab
witnessed so many success stories people
had it way worse than me
people have been in way worse positions
i met
people without arms and legs that i've
got they were shooting up shooting
themselves up
which was like
ridiculous
and
they got clean
and they started a different life
and they had it way worse than me
so to think about
think about like
suicide or anything loner's lines
it's not a coward's thing to say or to
think about it's part of immense mental
diseases
um disorders it's part of drug addiction
it's part of drug addiction
outside of people like
saying that oh like
you're you're a coward or adventure
thing about suicide or like this is that
because you have all this stuff in your
blast yeah they're blessed but it's part
of
um an
unbalanced chemical
yeah there's some chemical imbalance
yeah the drugs seem like a good solution
to the problem but the drugs are
actually they make it worse exactly it's
it's all it's all a part of that
it's not because the person it's just
because they can't see that they're
blessed
okay exactly what i said it's like
it's sometimes it takes
a success story
to show them
that like hey look you can turn it
around from negative to positive you
don't have to continue looking at the
negative
and then i've i've seen so many of those
that's why i keep that's why i'm still
probably still trucking you know what i
mean i know that
i can turn that negative positive i can
get better
i've seen it hope is an amazing thing
yeah it really is
there it is
i need to talk about that man
i don't know what i was gonna do
i'm glad you stopped by yeah i am too
it's great to see you again it's good to
see you man
josh i wish you
all the luck in the world man i'd love
to see you
get out of here and just just leave
everything behind you including
everything just everybody and everything
and just do something for yourself and
man i'd love to see you straighten your
life out
you can do it
you're a kid
it's not like you're 36 or 46 you're 56
you're 26.
appreciate it
you